the moves by angel the scenario i'm  always worried about that black puts all  the pieces in the attack but while  having played b4 a4  at some point  things will happen and it will be very  hard to continue the attack so i never i  really never liked the instructions for  black just  it is kind of very tricky structure  because you have to be always it's very  slow but at the same time you always  have to be careful and  and take a look how  it works because this is obvious that  black is doubling the rooks on the f but  after that what to do right yeah exactly  that's why well knight h2 of course  looks very strange but it's a plan i've  i've seen in very similar positions even  this i wasn't very comfortable with but  alejandra plays a normal king h2  which is the sort of typical way  yeah of course you make sure nothing  happens